good evening you're really going to have
the pleasure of presenting now is for
art direction and this year I must say
all the voters found it really a very
difficult decision important effect I
found it almost impossible was it harder
to create pre Hitler Germany than to
create pre hippie America or their
terrifying upside-down ship or the
favorite haunts of graham greene's
traveling on or indeed the youthful
haunts of England's wartime Prime
Minister we await the verdict now the
nominees for best achievement in art
direction ah
cabaret Ralph Z H Bauer and Juergen Kiba
set decoration
Herbert set decoration reg Ellen the
Poseidon Adventure
William creeper set decoration Rafael
Breton travels with my aunt
John box Gill / Ando and Robert W Lane
young Winston Don Ashton Jeffery Drake
John Grey's mark and William Hutchinson
set decoration Peter James and the
winner is Miss leachman's night not very
sharp the winners are
mr. rope
so I tried in English I'm very happy and
glad to get this great award but to tell
you the truth a part of it belongs to
Bob Fosse in another part to check on
what the cameraman thank you very much
everybody thank you